- [Man] Do you think that
the idea of hustle culture
is becoming
cliché?
The thing about your hustle is
it's hustle with
tons of substance.
- [Gary] Right.
- [Man] But I feel like there's a
lot of kids who are
just hustling to hustle.
- [Gary] I think a lot of kids
are saying they're hustling
to hustle. You know what I mean?
- [Man] That's what I'm getting at.
- [Gary] Yeah.
And by the way, by the way,
I'm just doing it to help the
people that are actually
trying to do it,
realize how much work it is.
I actually hope somebody
else comes out with
The Daily Z and shows
unbelievable work-life balance.
- [Man] Right. Right.
- [Gary] Just shows her or his
seven hour days but just
enormous amounts of happiness
with family and bowling
and learning new,
"I'm going to learn how
to knit this week."
I don't want to convince
anybody to do what I do,
I just want to clarify
to everybody that--
- [Man] When you say hustle
this is what you mean.
- [Gary] Look it takes
a lot of work.
You know the other thing
that's helped a lot of people
is people are like,
"Whoa, you're already
"more successful than I am,
and I'm working like half
"as much as you and
I thought I was working more
"than you 'cause I thought you
were kind of saying it but
"then reaping the
benefits of the riches.
"If you're still doing that,"
so it's a context point.
It's come up because of my
last 24 hours on Snap I think
not really.
- [Man] Okay.
- [Woman] It's interesting.
- Once, like four times a year,
I'll collapse and go to sleep
at 7 P.M. and I'll need a hard
core like 15 hour sleep but
and I started taking care of
my health about 2 years ago,
18 months ago and I don't think
I've picked up any more energy
when I was 25 pounds heavier
and eating like shit and
not exercising. I just have so
much natural adrenaline.
I showed up to somebody's
podcast yesterday
and he was Facebook Live-ing
and I went back and
read all the comments
last night at midnight
'cause I don't get tired,
and literally everybody's like,
"This guy's on fucking drugs."
Which is really interesting
and they meant it 'cause
they didn't know who I was.
They're like, "Why do all these
guys have to take drugs?"
And I was like "Fuck, I've
never even tried a cigarette."
"I've never done
anything in my life."
I've been left out from
all that good shit
and people still think it
'cause it's just natural DNA.
I truly think it's the
same way as being pretty
or 6-foot-5 it's just
something you were given.
I like it. I'm glad.
I like that I,
I truly, truly,
I really believe what
I'm about to say and
this is hyperbolized
to the moon,
I truly think I'm the hardest
working person on earth.
I truly believe that.
I just work 18 hours
a day everyday.
Like I just do.
- [Woman] Alright.
- [Gary] Cool.
Awesome.
- [Man] Gary Vaynerchuk.
Thanks guys.
(applause)
(light piano music)